le rideau se lève enfin sur un pan de
l'histoire pyrrhotine presqu'en latence
depuis plus d'un siècle
l'identité des 53 soldats de
saint-pierre morts pour la france
pendant la guerre franco allemande de
1870 horn ce monument une formalité pour
cette commune qui s'est vu supprimer
rattaché au carbet après la catastrophe
volcanique de 1912 est en cours pour ce
faire aujourd'hui c'est sur le puy
communauté parce qu'on est en train de
préparer depuis deux ans vous prenez
justement est vu en train de préparer
les anciens combattants présents à cette
cérémonie se souviennent des récits de
ce revenu de la guerre d'indochine
des témoignages qui ont déclenché leur
envie de servir la france vous avez fait
la guerre d'indochine
non non il était trop jeune je fais que
l'algérie le 61 69 62 et gtb censure
s'intégrer il va pas trouver mais savent
t-il toutes les péripéties traversées
par saint-pierre leur commune natale
cette bâtisse par exemple qui abrite la
mairie fait aujourd'hui aussi l'objet
d'une commémoration
elle a été inaugurée le 11 novembre 1934
saint-pierre prend alors l'alluré d'une
ville organise et administrativement
sauf que les archives emporté par
l'éruption d'appeler sont difficiles à
reconstituer l'identité des soldats
disparus a été retrouvé grâce à un
travail de recherche colossal mené par
sabine andriveau milthon et la
directrice du patrimoine
aujourd'hui les recherches nous mène à
des périodes wade documents qui ont été
conservés par d'autres administrations
et notamment par exemple les archives
d'aix-en-provence on aura aussi aux
archives départementales de la
martinique la ville de saint-pierre
disparaît en tant que tel entre 1902 et
1923 donc étendre et même les registres
d'état civil donc n'existe pas au nom de
la ville de saint pierre
donc c'est ça qui rend effectivement la
tâche encore plus compliquée la ville de
saint pierre n'a pas manqué non plus
d'honorer ces trois soldats morts pour
la france au mali et en irak cette année
en 2018
et depuis ce matin rené brand brand
ancien militaire élu à la municipalité
disparu n'y a pas si longtemps possède
sa plaque commémorative sur la place du
monument aux morts qui porte désormais
son nom